um Talk to Me growing up give me your
top five best albums ever your favorite
don't gotta be like just your personal
favorite
um all right Prodigy H and I see okay
okay Prodigy asiani's favorite Alchemist
beat ever on there keep it there you
like that album yeah I love that album
yeah he was talking to [__] like you
could just feel his confidence
confidence kind of like radiating
through
the music um let's go
Tim this is tough bro like all right
childhood yeah um Eminem The Eminem Show
okay life after death life after death
is the best album out of everything
though I think it's the best video
no out of all rap music that ever been
created life after death is
Superior like there's like rap albums
and there's like life after death okay
all right so just getting that clear so
I don't agree but life after death I
respect it The Eminem Show H and I see
oh
[Music]
I'm gonna go carter
Carter one oh that's the right one yeah
what you know about that people be
thinking it's Carter two Carter 2 is
fire Carter two did not age as well as
Carter one Carter one he got in his bag
no I think if you listen to both Carters
back to back right now Carter 2 does not
age as well I love Carter 2-0 because he
got on them Soulful beats and he went
really crazy for sure so like Birdman Jr
come on man I miss my dog what you know
about Birdman Jr oh my God that's what
made that's one of the songs that like
inspired me to go [__] ballistic on
that sounds crazy when he said [__] that
I'm going in yeah oh my God you sleep in
the field for trying the dude I'll bust
your head to the meat turn your mind to
fool that's Food For Thought think I
ain't lying to you a liar's body and
she'd set fire to my tires body and see
put the tires to him make him feel the
Escalade put his feet in the blade yo oh
my God I'm the heating the blade it was
like when he flows and she was just like
unconscious like I actually think that
like that song is like he's unconscious
and it's just going like this [__]
[__] I just try to listen I listen
to Carter 2 on a road trip recently and
I was like man Carter won aged better
Carter 2 is solid but I think Carter one
and three aged way better I think Carter
too damn Kev you're like hell yeah yeah
ill for knowing like Birdman Jr though I
mean I was I was working at Best Buy
when that [__] came out I bought it
don't get it twisted people not gonna
say that record I mean that's the one on
that album
um wasn't uh so that's four go DJ go DJ
was on there yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
miss my dogs so so I got I got I got
Wayne Carter one
product GH and I see big life after
death
um Eminem Show and let's go
um let's go let's go all eyes on me I
like it yeah
how crazy you did I just see the white
boy Ricky guy hosting the club somewhere
I'm not gonna front look right I was at
a Celtics game
and
I'm saying quartet and somebody I got a
lot of respect for he just facilitates
like celebrities and [__] like that he
hits me and said yo I want you to meet
my man white boy Rick he's at the game
looked over I seen a white dude with a
bust down chain and [__]
I'm like
isn't he a federal informant
if I watch the same movie we all watched
and then I asked my man like wasn't he
playing people in jail and [__] like I I
had to do like respectfully bro because
I really respect the person who brought
it to me like and he actually don't give
a [__] it's just people like it's coming
through Boston and they're like uh this
is this guy yeah this is so-and-so you
know what I mean he got so much [__]
going on
but I was like respectfully bro anybody
else you I would love to get introduced
to but I I don't want to be introduced
to him